there are a few types of people who play
competitive games online
you've got your everyday run-of-the-mill
law-abiding citizens I have done nothing
wrong ever in my life
you've got your Smurfs and you've got
the boosted animals boosting isn't a new
phenomenon it's actually been happening
since the earliest days of gaming but
recently it's taken on a different
meaning it's not just about soloqueue
mercenaries elevating low ELO plebs it's
about the insecurities created by
matchmaking systems that push people
down that dark and pitiful path [__]
boosting is pretty easy to understand on
the surface it refers to someone getting
a better player to play on their account
in a competitive game in order to
increase their online rank or boost it
this often leads to really terrible
players messing up your game by being in
way to higher rank for their actual
skill yeah I don't know man this this
lis is may be boosted but a low boosting
didn't start with high-level League of
Legends players taking you to plot it
actually started in universities decades
ago
[Music]
boosting goes as far back as in 1979 in
the game avatar a thrilling multi-user
dungeon that supported a whopping 40
players at a time which is actually a
pretty crazy number considering it was
an era where Sony had just released the
first walkman asteroids was considered
the greatest game ever made and
everybody was an ironic Lea in love with
Rod Stewart avatar could only be played
on the play-doh computer operating
systems the first ever generalized OS
which was really only available at major
universities the limited amount of gold
in each avatar world meant that people
exchanged real money for other players
gold if they were running short
meanwhile the severe punishments for
dying in-game meant that some players
found it easier to just buy a high-level
character off another player if they
lost theirs or wanted to get started
playing with friends of course that's
still a far cry from what we've got
today
in the late 90s real money trading
returned with mmo's like Ultima Online
which was also one of the first games to
enable gold farming by the time World of
Warcraft came out in 2004 an entire
industry sprouted up around gold farming
the hottest new form of real money
trading people in China were literally
working eighty four hour weeks in what
basically amounted to wow swag shops did
no sweatshop no excuse me I gotta go to
the can
in time gold farming evolved into power
leveling but as well started to lose
traction the RMT market needed a new
target and with the rise of MOBAs tied
to the rapid growth of League of Legends
in the early 2010's power leveling
became known as boosting boosting can
take a couple of forms you can hand the
keys to your account over to another
player and let them just win for you but
this approach requires faith that the
person boosting your account is going to
behave better than your
average league of legends ranked player
there's also the babysitting method
where you pay a better player to queue
with you and they carry you through your
games boosting services aren't cheap
either if you're playing League of
Legends a boost can cost you anywhere
from four to fifteen dollars per win and
anywhere from hundreds to thousands of
dollars if you want to get boosted into
a significantly higher rank I need a
[__] boost and I need it now meanwhile
boosters themselves are notoriously
shady game developers don't like people
messing with the competitive integrity
of their games
so most boosters don't like to reveal
themselves for fear of getting banned on
the other hand there are some players
who revel in being me outlaw tape jiong
opto sang Gil who is currently nursing
him 1,000 new ban on his main League of
Legends account because of his flagrant
attitude toward boosting opto was so
good at the game that many comparison to
the greatest players of all time but the
ban killed both his boosting and his
competitive careers but who gives a [__]
about making a living as a legit pro
player when you can have a plate full of
money from playing solo queue instead
it's easy to understand why a guy like
apto would boost the whole getting paid
to play video games thing is too much to
resist sometimes even if you are playing
on the long side of the terms of service
but the bigger question is why on earth
would anyone pay to be boosted if
smurfing is high level players ruining
lower Ehlo games then boosting is the
opposite you're paying to play at a
level you clearly do not belong at
[Applause]
to better understand we spoke to a few
boosters including an old halo 3 player
who used to boost people to 50 sometimes
after playing against the very people he
boosted and D ranking them they came
back to him for another boost I submit
you are illogical for a lot of people
boosting stems from wanting a reward
plenty of games offer rewards for
hitting certain ranks and the vast
majority of boosters are paid to get
lesser skilled players the exclusive
skins these guys who come back for
another boost after getting beaten by
their own booster they're a special case
as it turns out we have one of these
special cases in our office an admitted
boost e and he provided insight into his
shameful secret as long as his identity
remain protected at first I was being
boosted for the rank rewards but was
actually good enough to be the only
games I ever lost your teammates were
the problem oh yeah they were garbage
boosted for sure so what did you do well
so how did you end up doing not great it
turned out every teammate I had was I
still think have what it takes to be in
platinum I just need to get boosted back
up again to prove it you are a sad
strange little man and you have my pity
regardless of the ambitions behind being
boosted the hard truth is that you're
still a player in a rank where you don't
belong a lost puppy among wolves
basically a boosted animal or just
gusting a disgusting animal
[Applause]
see even though boosting is relatively
common it's pretty much always against
the terms of service of every single
game out there so most players aren't
exactly kind to boosters are used like a
cheater and a boosted duo right now I
think we have a cheater on our team I
think secret is a cheating great biggest
pig is getting boosted look at their us
art he was cold he was gold and silver
uh
I kind of want to throw the game if
people find out you've been boosted
you're basically a leper you're scum all
for either being delusional about your
skill or tying your personal worth to an
imaginary online ranking shame
[Applause]
the problem is that while plenty of
companies say that they hate boosting
their actions say something different
one of the other boosters we spoke to
told us that he didn't receive full
payment for a boost he gave a player all
the way to Diamond five after he wasn't
paid he decided to go to riot telling
them both that the guy was boosted and
that he was his booster riot didn't end
up doing anything at all and that
booster told us that he's heard of that
happening plenty of times those people
Pete those people up there the rich and
the powerful they do whatever they want
guys like us you me he'll care - there
it is boosting a frowned upon act that
started in the 70s but continues all the
way to today bringing downtrodden but
paying bronze players to places they
just don't belong if I could say one
thing to anyone if that being boosted is
being misunderstood and you really
shouldn't knock it till you try it well
thanks again for your time
no problem you're sure no one's gonna
know it's me your secret is safe with us
do you want to talk about shitty drinks
and the shittiest ring known as four
bits if you remember Orbitz Orbitz is
like the most [__] late nineties thing
you could think of just like a random
fear